- [Narrator] This Great Big
Story was made possible by IBM.
(upbeat piano music)
- [Narrator] Welcome to
- [Together] Girls Coding!
- [Narrator] And this Abisoye.
She created an initiative called,
you guessed it, Girls Coding.
(upbeat piano music)
It's aimed at teaching
girls from disadvantaged
backgrounds in Nigeria how to program.
- [Narrator] It started back in 2015.
Since then, they've been able to
teach coding to over 420 girls.
(clapping)
- [Narrator] Girls come from
all sorts of backgrounds.
Many come from the slums around Lagos.
The majority grow up thinking that
education isn't an option for them.
- [Narrator] But a few times
a week when they join this class,
they get a glimpse of a whole other world.
You want to stabilize or
you want to solve problems.
(upbeat orchestral music)
(note chiming)